（体を叩く音）
はい、はじめしゃちょー質問コーナー！！
ハイというわけで大変お待たせしました
と言いたいところなんですけど......も！
あのですね、とてもありがたいことなんですけども
視聴者（質問コーナー早く作れ！おそい！なにしてんだ！）
とてもありがたいことなんですよ
分かってるそれは！
楽しみにしてくれるっていうことは、とっても僕にとって
うれしいことなんですども
こう、なんだろうなぁ...
早く作れとか言われるとね...
やっぱりちょっとこちらとしては
なんていうのかな...
ちょっと...僕も作りたいんですけども
急いで作ってもいいものは、できないんですよ
で、僕としては、ちゃんとコメント欄をね
ギリギリまで見て答えたいなと思う質問をしっかり見つけてやりたいんで...
なかなかね、募集してから時間がかかるんですよ！
動画を作るのに
なので僕は、あえて「この日に出します」っていうことは、いわないんですけども
早く出せとか遅いとか言われるとね...
ちょっと焦っちゃうしちょっとなんかやらされてる感が出ちゃって
な....なに？わかるっしょ！
宿題が出ました！
お母さんとか家族の人が
マミー（あんた早く宿題しなさい）
って言われるとやる気なくなるじゃん！
そういう感じです。
自分がやりたいと思っても、無理に、こう...やれやれって言われると
ちょっとやる気がなくなっちゃうみたいな感じなんで
質問コーナーまってくださったり楽しみにしてくださるのは
とてもありがたいんですけども
僕のペースでやりたいと思ってるんで
あんまり！
煽られると！
僕もメンメンしちゃうんで！！
あんまりね！煽る行為は、おやめくださいね。
親に勉強しなさいって言われていわれて嫌な気分になる人達の気持ちです（泣）
もしまたね質問コーナーする時があったら時間かけてつくりたいんで
温かい目で待っていただけるとありがたいです。
これからもよろしくお願いしますm(_ _)m
では、早速質問コーナー行きましょう！！
あーもうなんかどうでもいいや
どうせえらばれないよね。
でもこんなやりとりしてるとー
それなー笑
もしかするとー？
まさかのー？
選ばれ、、、、
まさかの～？
まーさーかーのおーーー
そんなこといってたら...
来ちゃたりして...！？？
こんな話をしてると？？
もしかして～？
もしかすれば？
まぁ、さぁ、かぁ、のぉ～？
ほんとのほんとにぃー？
もしかして～？
いやいやいや、はじめんもそこまでバカではではないでしょーーーー。。。。。
でも、もしかしたらーーーー？ｗ
まさかの～？
そのまさかのまさかのもしかして・・・
そのまさかのまさかのまさかのーー
ｗｗ
そのまさかという事はーー！
えらんだけど～....
めちゃくちゃ多いな！
おいシメジ！！！.....がんばれよ
なんだよ！シメジって.....
...ありがと
うん。
はぁ？
はあぁぁ！？
ああぁん？
あ”あ”あ”あぁぁぁん！？！？
廊下に立ちなさい
・・・・・・
いやいや、なんでだよｗ
はじめ！！！！ふぁ○きん！！！！！
おい！
ジャンプしながらくしゃみをしてくださいﾍﾟｺﾘ
っへあっはぁぁぁぁぁん！！
はっｗはっｗはｗ
なんだこれは！！
全力でにっこにっこにー♡
あなたのハートににこにこにー♡
笑顔届ける矢澤にこにこ～♡
あーだめだめだめ～♡はじめーはみんなのも,の♡
を超全力でやってください。
ニッっコニッコニ～～～！！！
あなたのハートに～...
ニコニコニー！！！
笑顔届けるぅ～矢澤～にこにこー＾＾
あ”あ”あぁ！ダメダメダメ～～
はじめんは...みぃーんなの♡モ♡ノ♡
気持ち悪い！
はじめんは同じ作業を何度もすることが多いですが
「うぉぉおお！やめた、むり、やすむ」とかってならないんですか？
僕のすごいところって
特技がないことなんだ（キリッ）
特別なことができないんですけども
僕に唯一できるっていうのが
その続けることっていうか...集中力ですね！
自分のしたいこと限定なんですけども
集中力だけは、もうめちゃくちゃあります。
それが僕の唯一の武器です。
叫ぶなよ？！
馬鹿野郎！
２２歳にもなってこんな夜中に
叫ぶ奴がいると思うk(ry
キャァぁあ”ぁァァァ！！！
「バナップは～背後霊」って叫んでください!!
お願いします...まぁ...採用されないだろうな(´・ω・｀)
バナップは～～～.....背後霊！！(^Д^)
これ何？？
トイレ大好き
頭大丈夫か？
エ”エ”ア”ブルゥゥゥ！！？！
今までの動画の中で一番金を使ったものは何ですか？
今までの動画で
一番お金を使ったのは、ギネス記録！
１２０万円です！！
イベントも盛り上がったし
来てくれたみんなも楽しんでくれたんで
僕は良かったです。
さーカメラをアップしてもっともっといーよー
そしてスマイル！
かっこいいよはじめ！！
パンっ！
ありがとう！
笑いながら等速直線運動
HAHAHAHAHAHA
醤油１リットル飲めるんですか？
飲めねーわ（真顔）
頭かゆい
うん
死んだ
生き返った
人の命で遊ぶなぁ！（怒）
顔面を赤く染めて下ちい。
ぐうぅぅぅおおおおぉぉぉ
クブヂュブドドッググッぐぐぐぐぅ！？！
ぐおぉぉぉっぉお！！
はぁあ！！
ｂｅｆｏｒｅ　　　　　　　　　　　　 ａｆｔｅｒ
今話したい誰かがいる？いない？
基本的に１人でいたんで
できれば１人で居たい！
ポッキー食べたらボ○キーした
っはｗっはｗはｗｗ
！
！？
ペヤングそのままかじってください！！
パリパリ
ボリボリボリ（咀嚼音）
がぁぁあああ...ポロ
味がねー
前転して壁走ってキメ顔でdaisuke
し終わったあとに思いっきり好きだー！！と叫びつつ
実はそうでもないと思いながらでもそんなこと思っちゃダメだと
勉強してください。
おかしいだろ！
全力でメグミさんの真似して
はい皆さんこんにちは
メグミチャンネルへようこそ！
今日商品紹介するのは、こちら
リボルテック手袋の紹介です。
このフォルム！素晴らしい
もう最高！たまんないね！
う～んもう食べちゃいたいね！
ハグシャグシャぁぁ（咀嚼音？）
ウマウマウマ！！
ピギョォー！？
ウマーイ！
最高もうたまんない！
イッ匕ヒヒヒ
まずいな
すいませんでした！！
闇の帝王に選ばれし戦士
はじめーんよいま来ている服を
闇の力を開放し破り捨てるのだ
さぁ
デャァァァああ”あ”！！　（服を2つに破る）
なにしてくれんだよぉ！
おぉぉぉぉ↑いぃぃ！
服がぁふくがぁあ！！
（泣）
あ
ハイというわけでですね
今回もたくさんの質問ありがとうございましたm(_ _)m
月１だとペースが早いと思ったんでですね
まぁ
またね！
僕の良きタイミングで
質問コーナーやろうと思います。
次やるときはみんなそう....カッカせずにね
冷静に冷静に！
のんびりと気楽に待ってくれると
僕も助かります。
ではみなさん！次回の動画でお会いしましょう！
じゃぁな！！
最後まで動画のご視聴ありがとうございました
この動画が少しでも面白かったら
チャンネル登録お願いしますm(_ _)m